I don't know what the [__] going on
there's some sort of [__] movie
coming out where there's a mermaid
and there's a uh whoever's doing the
voice is not white and I guess the
mermaid's white and there's like white
people who actually are taking the time
to give a [__] it's live action
yeah oh it's live action so she's in it
yeah yeah oh so she's in it and they're
upset why because this fictitious thing
isn't that and then they're gonna sit
there and act like that's most white
people that they actually give a [__]
about a mermaid movie
I think that's another thing too but
rather than presenting those people as
Lunatic Fringe people they present them
as the average everyday person walking
down the street right it's like the
average everyday person walking down the
streets like me you don't even know the
[__] movie's coming out I don't think
I think it's a smaller percentage but
since they make the loudest noise that
the media runs with it